Tom Marcus spent 10 years as a
surveillance agent for British
intelligence Tom isn't his real name
were not allowed to show his face and
this interview has been authorized by
mi5 if we've been briefed on a target
that we need information and we go and
hunt them and we go and find everything
that we can about them we watch
everything they do and essentially as
soon as they come onto our grid and we
need to know all the information about
them our surveillance teams myself
included will go out there and find them
and make sure we control everything they
do how regularly were you avoiding
attacks all the time all the time and
and to follow tight it doesn't have to
just be weekly monthly some sometimes
sometimes daily on one operation
tom was nearly kidnapped by the
terrorists he was tracking something
we'd never ever seen before in UK soil
and it came it came very very close to
them bundled me into a van and second me
to a an address that we let that we
later search with Special Branch where
they found you know plastic sheeting on
their ground and a video camera in the
flag and a butcher's knives and it was
it was really down to the wire on
another occasion Tom Marcus was part of
an mi5 team tracking a suspected
Islamist terrorist
he was chucking it down and I was
dressed as a [ __ ] pretending to ask for
change and my own clothes soaked in my
own urine to complement that cover there
was more women worship as they had left
the mosque than had gone in so I looked
at the team saying there's a possibility
he changed the appearance the suspect
had changed into a burka
to disguise himself the mi5 team called
in a special forces unit to Range Rovers
slammed into the suspect's car as the
team came in incredibly quick and the
Range Rovers dragged him out the car
they found weapons and and pipe bombs in
the boot of the car and he's planned
target was the very next day because
they saw was at night there was the very
next day to be waiting for a couple of
coach full of children returning from a
trip to France and he was going to kill
them
the teachers and the parents it isn't
just Islamic extremism that threatens UK
security Chinese and Russian agents
operate on British streets and they're
good
Russians particular the Russians their
intelligence agents are extremely
effective extremely effective they are
so well trained in counter-surveillance
the ability to stop and identify prey is
like me Tom left mi5 with post-traumatic
stress with the agency's permission he
has written a book about his time as a
spy as we walk and talk just across the
road from mi5 headquarters his former
office he tells me how colleagues of his
were killed on operations but he says he
and they never did it for recognition
and he misses the job every day Alastair
bunk will sky news